humans have domesticated animals as
beasts of Burden for thousands of years
and the vital role horses play in the
evolution of culture in particular has
inspired countless equine folklore but
none are quite like the Centaur with the
lower body of a horse and upper body of
a human they maybe should be dismissed
as a completely impractical creature but
even with dubious Origins history has
embraced the lore of the centaur
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
a centaur is always upper half human and
mostly always lower half male horse the
centaurs of antiquity were not known to
be docile quite the opposite they were
violent meat eating predatory creatures
that hunted and terrorized humans in
lore the human half of the Centaur often
represents civility while the horse half
is bestiality and uncontrollable desire
depictions of centaurs trace the monster
back as far as the Babylonian period in
the 16th century BCE to when the casites
entered the Fertile Crescent on
Horseback and seized control of southern
Mesopotamia they used carved boundary
stones called kuduru to indicate land
transactions some of these artifacts
depict centaurs a human man attached at
the Torso to the body and legs of a
winged horse and examples produced
between 1186 to 1172 BCE near what is
now Iraq the centaurs are depicted
hunting with bows and weapons and likely
served as symbols of protection or
warning casite influence likely extended
to the Aegean civilizations including
the Mycenaean Greeks while it is unknown
exactly when their cultures interacted
many scholars believe that the two
influence one another and they may have
introduced the idea of the Centaur to
Greece where it really took hold in
folklore and culture the Centaur began
to appear in Greek art beginning in the
10th Century BCE the lefkandi Centaur is
believed to be the oldest such example
while all four legs of this Centaur
appear to be hooved bronze and
terracotta artifacts from 6th and 8th
Century BCE show the Centaur with the
full-legged body of a man with the rear
end of a horse seemingly grafted onto
the back around the 8th Century BCE two
Centaur origin stories dominate Greek
texts the benevolent demigod hiron The
Immortal instructor and the vicious race
of centaurs Heron is the half-horse
half-human son of a nymph name felira
and the Greek god of time Kronos
versions differ on who exactly is
genetically responsible for hiron's
horse half in some versions filira
desperately shapeshifts into a mare to
avoid kronos's unwanted advances only to
have him take the form of a stallion and
attack her anyway in the other version
the two are happily engaged in an affair
until they are caught in the act by
kronos's wife Ria to avoid being caught
the god of time quickly shifted into a
horse to avoid his wife identifying him
filirah is horrified when she births a
half-horse baby and abandons him Apollo
and Artemis take the child in and under
their Divine instruction the Chimera
demigod becomes a notable healer
astrologer Hunter and prophet he marries
a nymph and they have multiple children
he also becomes a teacher to Infamous
Heroes Perseus Achilles and Heracles in
the early 5th Century ancient Greek poet
pindar gives us the second canonical
Centaur origin story that of ixion and
the race of centaurs who who are far
less noble these creatures are the
grandchildren of ixion King of the
lapiths and nephili who's basically a
cloud made into a beautiful woman after
ixion assaults nephilis she gives birth
to a unique son depending on the story
this is either the first horse human
hybrid a true monster or a human man
named centauros who would eventually
mate with multiple magnesian mares
unions that all resulted in herds of
hybrid children either way it's a dark
story the race of centaurs are often
portrayed as lust-filled drunk dangerous
beings sexual assault and violence
underscore almost all encounters and
that's before we get into the center of
Mackie or what I like to call the bloody
wedding the center of Mackie is a key
part of Greek mythology an epic battle
between the centaurs and the lapiths in
aeolian tribe that began when the hybrid
race got really drunk and tried to rape
all the women at the wedding including
the ride for the Greeks the Centaur race
was a representation of dangerous hyper
masculinity they can't hold their liquor
and they're physically and sexually
violent Homer refers to the race of
centaurs as Mountain bred animals for
the ancient Greeks the mountains were
synonymous with danger directly opposing
the groomed fertile planes associated
with civilization the connection between
centaurs and sexuality particularly sex
outside of a marital union marks them as
ready metaphors condemning such
practices in the real world given that
they are also associated with negative
animality just look at the centaur's
forefather ixion he gets out of paying a
dowry by killing his father-in-law tries
to seduce Zeus's sister slash wife and
gets with a cloud not exactly a pillar
of the community and he ends up pinned
to a flaming wheel for all eternity the
entire history of the centaurs from
their very creation is marked with
negativity according to Greek lore all
the centaurs were slaughtered by
Heracles after a centaur named nesso
tried to steal Heracles bride hiron
tries to intervene but is grazed by a
poisoned Arrow unable to die but in
great pain he exchanges his immortality
for prometheus's freedom upon his death
he is placed in the stars as the
constellation centauros or Sagittarius
Iran is the only exception to centaur's
representation of the supposedly
uncivilized other and the Greeks
attempts to demonize cultures they found
barbaric unpredictable on the fringes of
society and more animal than human they
provide a ready scapegoat one that
unfortunately would be applied to real
people ancient Greek and Roman art
suggests that the centaurs were
metaphorical exaggerated representations
of the Persians replacing real outsiders
with monstrous fictional Outsiders it
has also been argued that the Centro
Mackie may be a fictional representation
of the real conflict between the archive
and theban people before 1200 BCE
hailing from the Argos region the
archives were famous for their horses
and agriculture the aptly named city of
Thebes was an influential Hub of trade
the Parthenon in Greece includes the
center of Maki in its architecture the
marble sculptures depicting the monsters
as muscular threatening opponents to the
humans rearing triumphantly over their
kills the Temple of Apollo epicorios is
also adorned with images from the center
of Mackie but the centaur's human heads
are older bearded men and the assaults
are more sexually graphic in all these
hard-won Centaur human battles the Greek
male citizen triumphed emphasizing their
importance and visibility in Greek
culture during and after the real
Persian Wars the creation of the
city-state or paulus bound Greeks
together with a centralized democratic
government and a shared language social
hierarchy within the palace was
determined by birth and gender at the
top free adult men born legitimately to
Citizen parents AKA The Heroes of the
Centaur stories below them foreigners
and foreign residents aka the centaurs
in an effort to establish legitimate
citizen ship for Greek heirs Greek men
were to marry virgin Greek women
foreigners depicted as centaurs
threatened Greek citizenship and
government with their sexual
lasciviousness
there is some argument to be made about
the novelty of the writer on Horseback
when such mounts were first encountered
by cultures whose ecosystems did not
naturally include horses whether seen
first in war trade or Conquest the shock
of seeing a human on Horseback may have
given some inspiration for the centaur
to that point some Scholars argue that
the Centaur myth may be based on the
first Mountain riders in the thessaly
region pre-trojan War tribes believed to
be named Centaur and lapith the Centaur
people according to Greek author
paleophetus hailed from a village named
nephili during ixion's reign as king a
herd of wild bulls terrorized the region
and inhabitants of Nepali were the only
ones daring enough to ride horses into
the herd of bulls slaying them with
javelins
after they were rewarded by the king
they turned hostile towards the town's
people of Larissa called lapis
kidnapping women and burning homes
before retreating to the mountains but
follyapetus is known for trying to
rationalize myths so who really knows
other attempts to bring the Centaur to
reality include pre-socratic Greek
philosopher and pedocles who proposed a
theory of human evolution that included
the centaurs as part of ancient
generations of animals that existed
before species differentiation there
were also reports of real centaurs in
the early first century CE Roman Emperor
Claudius received word that a centaur
had been found reportedly captured in
Arabia and transported to Egypt as a
gift for the emperor it was said that
the meat-eating creature did not survive
the changing climate after its death it
was embalmed and sent to Rome Emperor
Claudius displayed the embalm Centaur
with a face fiercer than a human face
hairy arms and hands and atani Maine at
his Palace while this story seems like
fiction there is a bit of fact or rather
trickery the supposed Centaur submerged
in Honey was likely made from the
mummified remains of humans and Horses
The Honey not only preserved the corpse
but would have been difficult to look
through a blurry Centaur is more easily
believed the creature was still on view
nearly a century later you would think
such hoaxes would have faded with the
development of biological studies but in
the 1980s a supposed Centaur skeleton
was exhibited in the U.S created by
zoologist William Willers as a social
experiment The Remains now reside in the
John C Hodges library at the University
of Tennessee Knoxville as an art
installation beginning in the 6th
Century CE centaurs and seders became
increasingly conflated with the former
disappearing from the retelling of myths
even though their image remained in art
it seems the centaurs were too
Supernatural too uncivilized however in
the Middle Ages centaurs began
reappearing in Christian churches
associated with bestial desires or even
the devil on the hunt for Souls they
retained the negative associations of
the past centaurs would go on to appear
in Dante's Divine Comedy as the
inhabitants of the first ring of the
seventh circle of hell you know the one
with the river of blood they stand on
the banks as jailers of the souls
boiling in the river shooting arrows at
any who try to escape centaurs
increasingly moved from presumed fact to
fiction by the 19th century
interpretations of the Centaur focused
on their connection to Nature with the
creatures personifying tornadoes or
Mountain Streams centaurs today occupy
the fantasy genre appearing in books and
movies as dangerous but fantastic
creatures given the genre's Mass Appeal
and often younger Target demographic the
brutal violence particularly sexual
violence is mostly downplayed in favor
of more culturally digestible pieces of
the monster's ancient origins in C.S
Lewis's Chronicles of Narnia they are
strong Noble bearded Warriors who fight
for good along Aslan while physically
imposing Louis makes sure Centaur
characters are positioned as educated
civilized allies who excel in medicine
and reading the stars in JK Rowling's
Harry Potter series centaurs are
likewise intelligent healers and quite
skilled at archery astronomy and
divination almost all choose to remain
apart from humans seeing that as
Unworthy of attention since they have
already read their Fates in the Stars
even though Rawlings interpretation
attempts to make the creatures
respectable they are also portrayed as
wild and uncivilized which takes a
disturbing turn when temporary Hogwarts
had mistress Dolores Umbridge is carried
off by centaurs into the woods and
returns incapable of speaking with bits
of twigs and leaves in her disheveled
hair Rawlings centaurs seemed to retain
as much of ixion as they do of hiron I'm
sorry
I must not tell lies what are you doing
in Rick Riordan's Percy Jackson series
the original Heron of Greek myth teaches
the heroes of the story at first
choosing to hide the lower half of his
body with a blanket and a wheeled box
with fake human legs in the books at
least the Centaur race also appears
described as talented Warriors and big
Partiers while threads at the original
centaurs linger today the Centaur is
more commonly used as a symbol that
unites rather than divides humans and
animals because the Centaur is made from
two beans that really exist not entirely
fictional beasts they are more easily
transmissible and translatable across
time positive or negative they force us
to confront our relationship with
non-human animals as both celebration
and condemnation of the human animal
relationship
Wes abroad a bronze Arrowhead
the brutal violence particularly sexual
violence is mostly down paid it
it's definitely epicurios
epicorios at at first choosing the Hind